الساعات الماضيه ممكن نعانونها بعنوان
واحد الملياردير في مواجهه مع الصحافه
الغربيه
على صحيفتين بريطانيه وامريكيه او الهجوم
يمكن الاقصى كان ضد صحيفه البريطانيه
فالصحيفه نشرت مقال تكلمت في عما سمته
بفشل تويتر في ازاله تغريدات فيها كراهيه
من حسابات في المانيا المقاله الصحيفه انه
تويتر من اول ما استحوذ عليه وانه خطاب
الكراهيه زاد ثلاثه اضعاف من وقت ما اشترى
تويتر تويتر ردت على الاتهامات هذه
بتغريدات من حساب تويتر سيفتي المختص بامن
الحسابات والتحديثات ووضحت بالتفصيل ردها
على ادعاءات
اللي بيقولوه مو صحيح واعتبروا المقال
مضلل وماسك اعاد تغريد الرد هذا وعلق عليه
وقال عيب عليكم
كانت ضمن اللي هاجمهم ماسك لا كمان
من الحب جانب وعلى فكره واحده من صحف
غربيه عديده مو على وفاق جدا مع ماسك
مؤخرا فاللي صار مع نيويورك تايمز انه
مجرد ملاحظ هجومها على ماسك مؤخرا ودعمها
لمارك ذكر بيرج ضده وكنوع من السخريه من
الصحيفه المغرد اتنبا بعنوان مقال جديد في
نيويورك تايمز بخصوص المعركه المرتقبه بين
ماسك اوزاك على ارض الواقع في الحلبه وقال
انه راح يكون عنوان المقال الذكر برج جميل
واو وثلاث رائع ومارك اكيد راح يفوز
بالملاكمه فرد عليه ماسك بايموجيات سخريه
وضحك وغطينا البعض منها لانه فيها اشاره
للمسابقه غير قابله للنشر اللي كان اعلن
عنها ماسك من ايام وعلى سيره المعركه
المرتقبه واللي كل الناس بتتساءل راح تصير
بين ماسك وذكر او لا فصور ذكر خلال
تدريباته رياضه الامم اي اللي من فتره
بيتدرب عليها ماليه منصات وعنوانها العريض
انه مارك بيستعد لمعرفته مع الم وبيظهر
مارك في الصور ببنيه جسديه قويه بين بصلين
من ابطال فنون القتال في اليو اف سي في
لاس فيغاس ونشر البطل النيجيري والملاكم
السابق
اديسانيا صورهم مع مارك زاكربيرج وعنوانها
بانه مارك ما عنده مسح وهو فعلا بزنس مان
جدي يعني كانه جالس كيف اصير رساله للماسك
انه انتبه ترى بيتدربوا اموره يعني تمام